comme vous le savez vendredi 14 avril le
conseil est constitutionnel a validé
pour l'essentiel la loi sur nos
retraites et je l'ai donc logiquement
promulgué les évolutions prévues par
cette loi entreront en vigueur
progressivement à partir de cet automne
adopter conformément à ce que prévoit
notre Constitution ces changements
étaient nécessaires pour garantir la
retraite de chacun et pour produire plus
de richesses pour notre nation
car en effet alors que le nombre de
retraités augmente que notre espérance
de vie s'allonge la réponse ne pouvait
pas être de baisser les pensions elle ne
pouvait pas être non plus d'augmenter
les cotisations de ceux qui travaillent
elle ne pouvait pas être comme je l'ai
beaucoup entendu de ne rien faire car
c'était alors laisser les déficits
s'accumuler et notre dette augmentée
pour les générations futures
ces changements étaient donc nécessaires
et constitue un effort c'est vrai
mais il est accompagné de mesures de
justice
d'amélioration concrète pour ceux qui
ont eu des carrières longues exercées
des métiers les plus durs ou qui
perçoivent des petites retraites
travaillez tous progressivement un peu
plus comme l'ont d'ailleurs fait tous
nos voisins européens c'est aussi
produire plus de richesses pour notre
pays tout entier et c'est ce qui nous
permet d'être plus fort d'investir pour
notre quotidien et pour notre avenir et
nous en avons besoin
pour autant
cette réforme est-elle acceptée à
l'évidence non et malgré les mois de
concertation un consensus n'a pas pu
être trouvé et je le regrette
nous devons en tirer tous les
enseignements
j'ai entendu dans les manifestations une
opposition à sa réforme des retraites
mais aussi une volonté de retrouver du
sens dans son travail dans améliorer les
conditions d'avoir des carrières qui
permettent de progresser dans la vie
plus généralement c'est une colère qui
s'est exprimée
colère face à un travail qui pour trop
de Français ne permet plus de bien vivre
face à des prix qui montent qu'il
s'agisse du plein des courses de la
cantine car malgré une mobilisation de
l'État inédite en Europe l'augmentation
des prix pèse sur nos vies quotidiennes
cette colère c'est aussi une colère
parce que certains ont le sentiment de
faire leur part
mais sans être récompensé de leurs
efforts ni en aide ni en service public
efficace
c'est toute cette colère que de très
nombreux Français ont exprimé en
manifestants et pour l'immense majorité
dans le calme et le respect de nos
institutions
personne et surtout pas moi ne peut
rester sourd à cette revendication de
justice sociale et de rénovation de
notre vie démocratique en particulier
exprimée par notre jeunesse
la réponse
ne peut être ni dans l'immobilisme ni
dans l'extrémisme
face à ses colères à ce sentiment de
déclassement d'abandon
nous devons agir ensemble au-delà des
clivages comme j'ai toujours cherché à
le faire au service d'un CAP clair celui
de notre indépendance et de la justice
oui notre indépendance d'abord pour la
France et pour l'Europe nous sommes un
peuple qui entend maîtriser et choisir
son destin nous ne voulons pas dépendre
de qui que ce soit ni des forces de la
spéculation ni des puissances étrangères
ni d'autres volontés que la nôtre et
nous avons raison mais l'indépendance ne
se décrète pas elle se bâtit par des
ambitions des efforts au niveau national
européen sur le plan du savoir de la
recherche de l'attractivité de la
technologie de l'industrie de la défense
et elle se finance aussi collectivement
par le travail
c'est indépendance française et
européenne et justement celle qui nous
permettra d'obtenir plus de justice que
chacun récolte davantage de tous ses
efforts que les inégalités de départ
soient mieux corrigées que les vies
soient moins empêchées que les plus
démunis soient davantage été c'est là le
grand projet que je porte devant vous et
avec vous
reconstruire et retrouver l'élan de
notre nation
ne rien céder aux divisions et au
contraire tenir ce cap pour notre
indépendance au service de cette idée de
la justice si française et ouvrir ou
reprendre pour cela trois grands
chantiers
d'abord le chantier du travail
face au chômage nous avons des résultats
inédits et indiscutables c'est le fruit
des transformations de ces dernières
années et de nos efforts à tous oui nous
avons créé en six ans un million 700 000
emplois pour notre pays
après le succès de l'apprentissage pour
nos jeunes je veux désormais engager la
réforme du lycée professionnel pour que
le plus grand nombre de nos adolescents
et de nos jeunes accèdent soit à des
formations vraiment qualifiantes soit à
l'emploi
nous redoublerons aussi d'efforts pour
ramener vers le travail le plus de
bénéficiaires du revenu de solidarité
active en les accompagnant mieux de
manière très concrète dans leur vie
le travail doit aussi mieux payer
en six ans nous avons décidé des hausses
conséquentes du salaire minimum ou de la
prime d'activité mais face à la
situation que je viens de décrire au
colère que je viens de rappeler nous
devons agir de manière encore plus
vigoureuse
c'est pourquoi j'ai proposé de recevoir
les organisations patronales et
syndicales dès demain matin pour celles
qui sont prêtes et la porte sera
toujours ouverte
et cela afin d'ouvrir sans aucune limite
sans aucun tabou une série de
négociations sur des sujets essentiels
améliorer les revenus des salariés
faire progresser les carrières mieux
partager la richesse améliorer les
conditions de travail trouver des
solutions à l'usure professionnelle
accroître l'emploi des seniors et aider
aux reconversions
ce nouveau pacte de la vie au travail
sera construit dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent par le dialogue social
et les accords très concrets au niveau
national mais aussi au plus près du
terrain que les organisations syndicales
et patronales seront trouvées
plus largement c'est par la
réindustrialisation que nous
retrouverons notre force et que nous
créerons des emplois mieux payés là
aussi nous avons des résultats
tangibles inédits
en France dans des vallées et des
cantons des usines ouvrent à nouveau 200
depuis 2 ans là
où notre pays c'était habituel à la
désindustrialisation nous recréons de
l'emploi industriel et nous sommes
devenus le pays le plus attractif en
Europe pour les investissements notre
nouvelle économie plus verte
respectueuse de nos terres et de nos
paysages n'est pas un rêve mais une
réalité qui nous permet de créer des
emplois et de tenir nos engagements pour
le climat
grâce à la planification écologique qui
sera dévoilée d'ici l'été nous irons
vers un nouveau modèle productif et
écologique dans l'agriculture le
bâtiment l'économie circulaire les
transports l'énergie et les technologies
un cadre aussi avec lequel nous serons
mieux parés face aux événements
climatiques comme la sécheresse estivale
le deuxième chantier est celui de la
justice et de l'ordre républicain et
démocratique
l'État de droit et notre socle et il n'y
a pas de liberté sans loi ni sans
sanction envers ceux qui transgressent
le droit des autres dans ce but nous
continuerons à recruter plus de 10 000
magistrats et agents continueront
d'améliorer le fonctionnement de notre
justice et nous sommes en train de créer
200 brigades de gendarmerie dans nos
campagnes
lutter contre toutes les formes de
délinquance contre toutes les fraudes
qu'elles soient sociales ou fiscales
sera aussi au cœur de l'action du
gouvernement avec des annonces fortes
dès le début du mois de mai
nous renforcerons aussi le contrôle de
l'immigration illégale tout en intégrant
mieux ce qui rejoigne notre pays
rénover l'ordre républicain et
démocratique signifie également que nous
devons lutter contre le sentiment
persistant que voter ne serait plus
décidé je proposais à cet égard en lien
avec la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale le président du Sénat le
président du Conseil économique social
et environnemental des grandes pistes
pour que le fonctionnement de nos
institutions gagne en efficacité mais
aussi en participation citoyenne comme
nous venons d'ailleurs de le faire avec
la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie
le troisième chantier enfin est celui du
progrès
progrès pour mieux vivre je veux que
chacun d'entre vous retrouve la
certitude que nos enfants pourront bâtir
une vie meilleure et ce sont nos
services publics qui devront porter
cette espérance de la petite enfance au
grand âge
dès lors l'éducation nationale doit
renouer avec l'ambition d'être l'une des
meilleures d'Europe dès la rentrée notre
école va changer à vue d'oeil pour les
enseignants qui seront mieux rémunérés
pour les élèves qui seront davantage
accompagnés en français en mathématiques
pour leurs devoirs et pratiqueront plus
de sport à l'école pour les parents qui
verront le remplacement systématique des
enseignants absents
notre système de santé sera aussi
profondément rebâti
depuis 6 ans 11 millions de Françaises
et de Français ont pu bénéficier du
reste à charge zéro pour leurs lunettes
leurs appareils auditifs ou leur
prothèses dentaire nous avons mis fin au
numérique clausus et nous avons
massivement investi dans notre hôpital
mais il faut des résultats concrets à
court terme d'ici la fin de cette année
600 000 patients atteints de maladies
chroniques qui n'ont pas de médecin
traitant en disposeront et d'ici la fin
de l'année prochaine nous devrons avoir
désengorger tous nos services d'urgence
et pour les quelques 10 millions d'entre
vous qui vivaient dans les quartiers les
plus défavorisés
dans les zones rurales les plus en
difficulté dans nos territoires
d'outre-mer
nous trouverons là encore des solutions
concrètes pour améliorer la vie
quotidienne
mes chers compatriotes ensemble nous
avons fait face à l'épidémie il y a de
nombreuses crises depuis six ans
attendent péril à chaque fois j'ai
cherché à libérer les énergies à
protéger les plus faibles à tenir
l'unité du pays avec le seul intérêt de
la nation comme guide
c'est le même esprit de responsabilité
qui doit nous animer au moment où nous
avons à relever sans attendre les défis
du changement climatique du
vieillissement des désordres
géopolitiques des révolutions
technologiques comme l'intelligence
artificielle ou les algorithmes
je me rappelle il y a 4 ans presque jour
pour jour
je m'exprimais sous cette forme devant
vous Notre-Dame de Paris venait de
brûler et je vous disais dès le
lendemain que nous rebâtirions en 5 ans
que n’avais-je alors entendu et tous les
commentateurs nous ont dit impossible
pourquoi ce cap intenable et bien nous
allons le faire
nous allons le faire parce que une
décision a été prise mais surtout parce
qu'il y a eu la volonté de chaque jour
et la mobilisation de tous parce qu'il y
a eu des milliers de femmes et d'hommes
partout à travers le pays pour œuvrer
ensemble et rebâtir
et bien il doit en être de même pour les
grands chantiers de la nation
et c'est pourquoi je sollicite toutes
les forces d'action et de bonne volonté
nos mères nos élus nos forces politiques
nos syndicats tous ensemble je compte
mieux les associer en relançant dès le
mois de mai des coalitions et alliance
nouvelle sur les bases solides du
Conseil national de la refondation au
plus près du terrain et chacun d'entre
vous avait un rôle à jouer il nous faut
moins de loi moins de bureaucratie plus
de liberté d'actions d'expérimentation
de pouvoir d'initiative à l'échelle de
nos vies oui
c'est cet élan national auquel je crois
et ces trois chantiers prioritaires
constituent la feuille de route du
gouvernement que la première ministre
détaillera dès la semaine prochaine
ces trois chantiers doivent nous
rassembler rassembler les principaux
responsables de la nation et je m'y
impliquerai
et le 14 juillet prochain doit nous
permettre de faire un premier bilan nous
avons devant nous sans jour
d'apaisement d'unité
d'ambition et d'action au service de la
France c'est notre devoir et je vous
fais confiance je nous fais confiance
pour y arriver
vive la république et vive la France
[Musique]
voilà vous venez de l'entendre Emmanuel
Macron qui s'est exprimé sur cette
allocution tant attendue cette
allocution qui intervenait juste après
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
qui entériné la validation de la réforme
de retraite qui a été promulgué
d'ailleurs
on va parler de cette allocution bonjour
on est ah voilà vous allez nous
retrouver au jour de maillot merci
d'être avec nous politologues enseignant
à l'université Paris Nanterre on va
parler avec vous on va débriefer un peu
tout ce qu'on a vu tout ce qui est passé
et ce qu'a dit Emmanuel Macron alors ça
ce sont des vieilles images on va en
parler aussi de ce déplacement mais déjà
est-ce qu'il faut retenir de ce qu'a dit
le président ce soir ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que le Président de la
République en fait nous propose un
programme on a un programme politique là
pour les pour les pour les quatre ans
pour le reste du mandat c'est assez
intéressant alors qu'on est dans une
situation où il n'a ni majorité
politique ni majorité sociale et où nous
sommes dans une peut-être une des plus
graves crises de la Cinquième République
puisque là on conjugue quand même une
crise économique rappelons-le avec la
l'inflation et la vie chère de manière
générale une crise politique avec cette
réforme des retraites qui est passée par
49-3 et qui est le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est refuser par la population et
une crise sociale par dessus le marché
donc vraiment c'est intéressant de voir
ce prénom de la République qui développe
un programme politique un programme
présidentiel même je dirais alors que
bon la présidentielle est terminée il
est élu on sait enfin on est censé
savoir pourquoi on l'a élu Emmanuel
Macron mais en vérité il n'a il est je
crois sans majorité et surtout
je suis pas certain qu'il ait compris la
gravité de la situation parce que même
quand il parle de la colère des Français
il se trompent sur les raisons de cette
colère peut-être pourquoi selon vous
bien parce qu'en fait il a mis en avant
le fait que les Français étaient
mécontents de ne pas pouvoir gagner
suffisamment par rapport à leur travail
ce qui est vrai hein je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui dans le pays est
partagé sauf que là actuellement la
crise elle est contre sa personne la
colère est contre sa personne je veux
dire je crois même qu'on a dépassé la
question de la réforme des retraites qui
étaient quand même le point de départ
quand même de cette contestation et on
est sur une crise qui est plus plus
globale et qui est contre contre sa
personne contre son pouvoir ce qui est
compliqué en début de mandat pour lui
moi je mange j'attends de voir les
quatre années qui viennent d'autant plus
qu'il a comme je le disais présenté un
programme ma foi pas inintéressant
d'ailleurs on peut on peut envoyer un
discuter mais je demande comment il
pourra le lancer oui effectivement les
progrès alors beaucoup de gens dans les
commentaires n'y comprends pas trop il
n'a fait que 15 minutes oui c'était
assez court comme comme discours mais en
tout cas pas de surprise on sort on s'y
attendait pas forcément mais il allait
pas retirer la réforme des retraites il
n'allait au moins ça je crois que les je
crois que les Français n'attendent plus
rien des allocutions présidentielles je
pense aussi qu'on a on a bascu dans une
autre époque mais au niveau de la
communication il y a plus d'attente sur
les allocutions présidentielles très
franchement et personne ne s'attendait à
ce qu'il nous fasse comme Jacques Chirac
l'avait fait à l'époque de la loi du
premier du contrat 1er embauche qui
était aussi une loi qui était très
contestée et qui était une loi qui
soulevait beaucoup de questions
économiques sociales et politiques
encore que celle-là avait été votée par
le Parlement il faut il faut quand même
le dire ou effectivement Jacques Chirac
avait refusé enfin n'avait pas promulgué
la loi comme ces prérogatifs
présidentielles le permettait je voyais
difficilement là Emmanuel Macron en
faire de même dans la mesure où cette
réforme il l'a porté et
en amont d'ailleurs pour la première
fois il en a parlé officiellement de
cette façon et il a même fait un petit
peu au début de la locution un petit peu
de pédagogie exactement ce qu'on a
reproché au gouvernement de ne pas faire
donc c'est assez amusant de voir que si
tardivement en fait on a le président de
la République qui intervient sur cette
question fondamentale et qui en plus euh
dans les travers habituels exactement
donc je suis assez surprenant en fait ce
début d'allocution particulièrement
j'avais même noté si vous voulez au
début de l'élocution il parle comme un
premier ministre et pas comme un
président de la République heureusement
dans la deuxième partie il est
effectivement parti sur un grand
programme qui qui annonce en fait des
réformes à venir moi je maintiens que il
va être très compliqué pour lui de les
tenir oui effectivement alors ce grand
programme d'ailleurs il nous a donné un
petit rendez-vous à la semaine prochaine
avec Élisabeth borne qui le présentera
officiellement alors on sait pas sur
quelle forme mais et en plus ça la
conforte finalement ça conforte la
position le fait de dire ma première
ministre va vous annoncer ça la semaine
prochaine première surprise Emmanuel il
n'y a pas d'annonce de remaniement
effectivement on aurait pu s'attendre à
une annonce de remaniement la première
surprise c'est Elisabeth borne passe
effectivement à travers pour l'instant
pour l'instant à travers cette crise et
va donc continuer à mener des réformes
c'est à dire ce qu'elle a déclaré sauf
erreur de ma part aujourd'hui même elle
va continuer les réformes et les
réformes là elles ont été annoncées par
le Président de la République à travers
un programme politique assez intéressant
où il on voit que l'indépendance
nationale avec la question de la
réindustrialisation et je trouve que
c'est c'est un un sujet effectivement
important d'une grande gravité est-ce
qu'il fallait le mobiliser à ce moment
là juste après avoir évoqué la réforme
des retraites et dans ce contexte où il
a très peu de sentiment populaire ça on
peut poser la question il a dit que il
regrette qu'il y avait pas de consensus
sur cette réforme de retraite et que il
recevra demain les indicats pas trop
d'eau et les autres syndicats les
investons patronales et les syndicats
également mais c'est pas sûr qu'ils se
rendent là-bas et d'autant plus que a
priori le le dialogue semble rompu pour
l'instant et lui a dit bah voilà moi ma
porte sera toujours ouverte pour vous
pour moi c'est une erreur politique et
et de façon plus grave encore c'est une
atteinte même à la fonction
présidentielle le président de la
République c'est un arbitre mais c'est
quelqu'un qui est aussi celui qui
garantit l'unité de la nation et donc on
va dire l'unité du peuple et des
Français de façon plus générale
appelé les partenaires syndicaux en
sachant pertinemment que certains ne
viendront pas et pour cause en raison de
la crise actuelle je trouve que c'est
assez c'est assez inconséquent de sa
part et c'est dangereux pour la bien des
institutions car qu'est-ce que cela veut
dire ça veut dire que Emmanuel Macron ce
soir nous a annoncé qu'il allait engager
de nouvelles réformes sur la loi sur le
travail principalement avec les
syndicats patronaux seuls puisque les
autres partenaires syndicaux ont dit
qu'il ne participeraient pas en raison
de la crise actuelle et du mépris
comment qu'ils ont subi dans cette
réforme des retraites qui non seulement
n'a pas été négociée avec les
partenaires syndicaux mais qui n'a pas
non plus été voté démocratiquement donc
il y a il y a un vrai de négociations
dans cette dans cette annonce où il dit
dès demain matin
nous commencer le travail en laissant
bien sûr quand même
en laissant la porte ouverte comme il
l'a dit effectivement
vos commentaires vous n'avez pas été
vous fera pas voter à la fin mais on n'a
pas besoin de chat vous avez été très
convainculé aussi peut-être un peu
changé les allocution présidentielles
qu'on croit en chantier
le premier chantier c'était le travail
et la suite défendu son bilan en disant
grâce à moi ça va mieux regardez on a
créé un million 700 000 emplois
finalement pourquoi vous m'en voulez
rien industrielle statistiques mais par
contre Emmanuel Macron a bien fait de
rappeler sa une grande réussite
fait partie des réussites d'Emmanuel
Macron dans la mesure en plus où il
l'avait inscrit à son programme donc de
favoriser l'apprentissage il annonce
aussi une une réforme du lycée
professionnel en tout cas pour les
Français il est certain que de manière
générale cette réforme du travail
inaugure rien de bon car
engager une nouvelle réforme sur le
front social après la réforme des
retraites dans le contexte actuel c'est
quand même c'est dangereux pour la
France mais c'est même dangereux pour
lui politiquement mais après Emmanuel
Macron il a 4 ans devant lui on se pose
la question aujourd'hui comment il va
être possible de gouverner de tenir et
bien et de tenir et bien lui il se pose
pas la question il sait qu'il va tenir
il en a visiblement la certitude ou du
moins il essaie de nous de nous en
convaincre effectivement deuxième
chantier la justice et l'ordre
républicain et démocratique il a lancé
la création de 200 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie dans les campagnes et le
recrutement de 10000 magistrats oui
alors ça c'est c'est recrutement sont
nécessaires je veux dire lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on étudie la fonction publique
liée à la répression donc maintien de
l'ordre et à la justice en France on est
on est frappé de de du sous du sous
nombre de fonctionnaires en la matière
donc ça c'est plutôt bienvenu et je
pense que ce sera apprécié mais une fois
de plus dans le contexte actuel où sa
parole est complètement démonétisée
comment ne pas y voir que renforcement
des moyens de répression contre un
mouvement social donc le président de la
République vous savez quoi qu'ils disent
aujourd'hui je pense que cela ne sera
pas compris même si tout n'est pas
négatif d'un point de vue j'entends
strictement objectif oui effectivement
et alors le troisième chantier c'est le
progrès nous avons doivent avoir une
pouvoir vivre une vie meilleure sur le
c'est ça et il a terminé un peu son
discours l'espérance du futur là encore
ça ne mange pas de pain au même titre
que la planification écologique qu'il a
annoncé pour l'été on nous attendons de
voir nous verrons bien mais je vois pas
ce que ça peut recouvrer en l'état il a
lié ça en plus à la réindustrialisation
quand même du pays en mettant en avant
la création de de 200 nouvelles
industries sur le territoire français
où est-ce qu'il veut aller avec ça nous
ne savons pas en tout cas ça fait partie
de l'affichage depuis le coup c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui depuis le début de ce de
ce mandat où il fait effectivement il
promettait une transition écologique une
planification écologique on a le terme
de planification ce soir est-ce que
c'est différent que de transition qui
avait été employé au précédemment je
pense que dans son esprit c'est assez
flou et c'est la même chose mais en tout
cas il veut montrer qu'il est à la
manoeuvre si vous voulez dans le champ
industriel et qu'il le fait de façon
écologique sachant que l'un et l'autre
ne vont pas forcément nécessairement
ensemble alors j'ai une petite idée de
la caisse de la réponse que vous allez
avoir mais est-ce que ça peut ça peut
calmer le peuple français une allocution
comme celle-ci je crois absolument pas
de manière générale de manière générale
en mettant de côté Emmanuel Macron je
pense qu'on peut aujourd'hui une
allocution présidentielle sa portée je
la trouve relative
on est dans une autre époque un autre
temps et même faudra qu'on regarde aussi
les les comment dire l'audimat de cette
allocution il est pas certain qu'elle
ait été beaucoup suivie c'est aussi
important sachant qu'on sait qu'il y a
eu le mouvement des casseroles qui
refusait d'écouter manuel Macron et qui
ont qui voulait même faire du bruit avec
des casseroles pour empêcher que qu'il
soit entendu quelque part donc déjà il y
a cela je pense qu'on est dans une autre
époque par ailleurs je vois
difficilement comment on peut sortir
d'une crise dans la mesure où il refuse
toute négociation et tout ah vers on va
le dire de façon globale l'opposition à
cette réforme des retraites le chef de
l'État est un et le garant l'unité
nationale dire dans il y a des il y a
des hors graves dans notre société il y
a des oppositions graves on est quand
même sur une population qui est selon
les sondages même avec les estimations
les plus basses à 80 85 % hostile à
cette réforme de façon plus globale ça
commence à entacher toute l'oeuvre
gouvernementale je pense que le chef de
l'État pour garder une marge de manœuvre
d'ici la fin de son mandat il aurait dû
si ce n'est retirer cette réforme du
moins négocier mais on en est on en est
très loin aujourd'hui c'est plus
possible il est allé trop loin il ne
peut plus reculer et d'ailleurs
l'opposition c'est la même chose elle
est allé trop loin elle ne peut plus
reculer nous sommes dans une impasse la
crise politique continue c'est pas cette
allocation allocution pardon qui va y
mettre fin il va jouer quelque chose on
rappelle d'ailleurs les propos de par
exemple Laurent Berger qui disait nous
on essaie de discuter ça ne marche pas
finalement c'est que la violence avec
les gilets jaunes en faisant est-ce que
c'est un peu ça que les les l'image que
renvoi Emmanuel Macron une fois de plus
aujourd'hui en disant réforme des
retraites malgré tous les gens qui
avaient dans la rue ça ne compte pas
finalement oui moi je suis assez
d'accord avec Laurent Berger pour cela
parce que si vous prenez tous les
mouvements sociaux importants des
dernières années et je vais inclure
vraiment
de façon tout à fait volontaire la manif
pour tous par exemple nuit debout aussi
place de la République et les gilets
jaunes en Suisse mouvement qu'on peut
pas tous qualifier soit de gauche soit
de droite et qui sont tous divers ce que
nous avons nous a montré nous ont montré
ces différents mouvements sociaux c'est
que la violence avait quoi qu'on en
pense elle avait des effets politiques
puisque il y a pas de négociation nous
sommes dans un système où l'État refuse
de négocier avec une opposition quand
elle se manifeste dans la rue certes ce
n'est pas la rue qui gouverne mais quand
vous avez 80% des Français qui sont
hostiles à une réforme où les gilets
jaunes qui je le rappelle étaient
soutenu dans ses proportions on l'a
oublié avec la crise du covid mais le
gilet jaune les gilets jaunes au pic de
leur actes de leur activité de leur
mobilisation ont été soutenus jusqu'à
80% de la population française
dans la mesure où il y a pas de
négociation la violence est
effectivement apparaît comme un recours
et lorsque le président de la République
a fait savoir de façon officieuse bien
sûr parce que le Président de la
République a fait savoir que rien ne le
ferait reculer hormis un mort des
violences ou un pays en feu
qu'appelle-t-il qu'appelle-t-il pour moi
il y a une vraie responsabilité dans les
violences que nous que nous subissons
actuellement et qui sont le fait bon
pour ce qui est de la réforme des
retraites de casseurs d'extrême gauche
qui sont bien connues la violence il
faut bien comprendre qu'elle vient du
sommet de l'État elle ne vient pas d'en
bas évidemment ils sont ravis les
casseurs de se saisir de ces
opportunités pour s'abonner mais c'est
provoqué par ces provoqué par une
arrogance politique qui vient du sommet
de l'État
c'est important de
de la à l'esprit et de ne pas isoler
comment dire par exemple les violences
qu'on a en marge de manifestation comme
étant suit génériste non il y a quelque
chose il y a une circulation si vous
voulez ça vient vraiment du sommet de
l'État il y a une responsabilité pour
moi qui est claire de la part du
président de la République dans les
violences actuelles je parle dans les
manifestations contre les retraites je
ne parle pas des mouvements qui
s'opposent par exemple aux grandes
bassines qui sont un autre un autre
sujet depuis tout à l'heure vous voyez
c'est ces images parce que ça c'est
intéressant aussi Emmanuel Macron qui se
déplace en France il y a eu deux
déplacements récemment c'était la à
Notre-Dame de Paris puis il y en a eu un
au lac de Serre-Ponçon fin mars sinon il
est parti à l'étranger au Pays-Bas et en
Chine est-ce qu'il va encore pouvoir se
déplacer en France parce qu'on a vu
d'ailleurs que la dernière fois le
parvis de Notre-Dame a dû être évacué au
moment où il est venu est-ce que il peut
finalement être un président de la
France public un chef d'État
qu'il y a des pouvoirs exécutif fort
comme le présent de la République qui
n'a plus la sentiment de son peuple
n'est plus crédible sur la scène
internationale ça il faut être très
clair si le général de Gaulle pour
apprendre des exemples historiques où
chaque Chirac a une autre époque ont pu
avoir une voix forte à l'international
alors que la France et là est une
puissance de moyenne impuissance
le général de Gaulle ou Jacques Chirac
ont pu avoir une voix internationale
c'est parce qu'ils avaient un soutien
populaire derrière eux un minima et
d'autant plus sur la question
internationale on voit qu'Emmanuel
Macron est contesté maintenant jusque
dans ses déplacements diplomatiques au
Pays-Bas on en est on en est quand même
arrivé là et ça c'est extrêmement grave
pour la crédibilité de la France à
l'international c'est certain et pour
savoir qui porte vous savez le c'est
très intéressant le le
les propos qu'a laissé passer le
président de la République au sujet de
Taïwan ce qu'il dit en fait est tout à
fait
intéressant et tout à fait discutable on
peut rationnellement discuter avoir des
réflexions débattre de ces positions
géopolitiques qui visent à essayer de de
trouver une sorte de troisième voie en
parlant à la Chine différemment que les
États-Unis ou la Russie qui est son
allié objectif
cette pensée qui n'est pas idiote
j'entends sur le plan diplomatique et
ruiner par cette cette absence de
d'assentiment dans la population à cause
donc toujours de cette crise sur la
réforme des retraites et c'est assez
inquiétant c'est inquiétant pour le
président de la République en tant que
personne mais c'est surtout inquiétant
pour pour la France de façon plus
globale et vous savez même dans même
sans aller aussi loin que la Chine au
niveau européen les partenaires
européens maintenant voient que Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas de majorité qu'il ne se
représentera pas c'est plus un
partenaire comme avant la plus même pas
politique quand on vit déjà quand on a
été élu au suffrage universel ce qui
était son cas quand même il y a pas très
longtemps c'est aussi FA avec Macron
cette capacité à se démonétiser aussi
vite il avait quand même une majorité de
Français qui ont voté pour lui qu'on en
pense même si bon beaucoup ont voté
contre Marine Le Pen certes il avait
quand même ce poids là ce poil là à
l'heure actuelle il est ruiné car il est
certain aujourd'hui qu'il y aurait pas
de majorité derrière lui dans le cadre
d'une nouvelle élection présidentielle
même si c'est scénarios fictions n'ont
pas beaucoup de sens on l'a sorti dans
cette interview ce qu'il a voulu c'est
tourner la page de la de la séquence
comme on dit en vente politique la
séquence retraite on passe à autre chose
parce que vraiment c'est terminé de
parler de de réforme de retraite comme
lui le veut écouter ça va être difficile
de prédire vous savez moi je ma
formation elle est historienne je suis
je suis historien avant tout et je peux
pas prédire l'avenir néanmoins le
présent de la République a un atout
fondamental sous la Cinquième République
encore aujourd'hui le fait que nous
soyons là aussi à à écouter à discuter
son allocution présidentielle en étant
on est quand même encore la preuve c'est
le maître des horloges c'est quand même
lui qui décide du tempo
démocratique et du tempo de la vie
politique en France est-ce que
l'opposition qui est farouche contre le
président de la République actuellement
va réussir à renverser cela je ne le
sais pas en tout cas jusqu'à présent et
la Constitution donne les outils au
président de la République pour que
effectivement il puisse mettre fin à
cette séquence mais là je ne suis pas
devin et je ne m'aventurerai pas plus
loin que cela alors je vais vous montrer
la question du jour puisque tous les
jours le Le Figaro on vous pose une une
question
elle va s'afficher dans un instant à
alors attendez on va attendre que
qu'elle s'affiche puisque je viens de la
perdre justement je voulais essayer
boire un petit peu d'eau comme ça en
attendant alors cette question du jour
tout simplement c'est avez-vous été
convaincu à la location d'Emmanuel
Macron je vais vous la montrer voilà les
tissus
vous Benoît Vaillot est-ce que vous avez
été convaincu
écoutez je vais être avec vous je ne
suis pas convaincu et je n'aurais je
n'aurais pas été convaincu dans la
situation actuelle très honnêtement
quand on a rien à attendre on ne peut
pas être déçu et on ne peut pas être
surpris si vous voulez voilà donc non je
suis je suis pas
convaincu du tout par la locution
d'Emmanuel Macron néanmoins je note tout
de même qu'il a essayé de de prendre un
petit peu de d'envergure sur la deuxième
partie de son allocution on essayant de
dessiner un grand trait les grands axes
de sa politique future mais néanmoins je
le redis combien même ce serait bel et
bon quelle majorité politique il a même
pas de majorité parlementaire alors une
majorité poétique dans le pays il l'a
pas quelle majorité sociale dans le pays
vous savez c'est c'est quand même
le président de la République était
minoritaire elle a toujours été
depuis même pas en premier mandat je
veux dire Emmanuel Macron était
minoritaire dans le pays en marche
Renaissance ça baisse quoi 25% et le
premier tour il a pas dépassé les 30%
premier tour Emmanuel Macron mais là il
est même sur son électorat de base il
est même en retrait donc je je ne suis
pas convaincu et je pense que les
Français ne le sont pas non plus
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire je vais vous montrer quand même ce
qu'on répondu les interdits du Figaro en
cliquant non puisque vous avez répondu
que vous vous n'étiez pas convaincu 65 %
des lecteurs de filières pour l'instant
vous voyez publié une minute donc c'est
très récent on va voir comment tout cela
évolue sur 7000 votants vous lisez pas
d'ailleurs vous les lecteurs du Figaro à
venir nous voir pour nous dire ce que
vous pensez de cette question qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait qu'il fasse Emmanuel
Macron aujourd'hui pour que pour sortir
de la crise finalement il fallait qu'il
retire ça il lui faut qu'il retire ça sa
réforme qui organise un référendum qui
qui change tout son gouvernement écoutez
je crois je crois qu'il est trop tard je
crois qu'il est trop tard pour être tout
à fait honnête il y a une solution qui
est toujours la bonne sur la 5e
République c'est évidemment changer non
seulement de gouvernement mais le
Premier ministre qui permet un petit peu
de faire diversion et de et d'insuffler
un peu de son nouveau
je pense ça ne fera pas diversion par
contre
il vient de la République à laquelle il
pense depuis le début
de son mandat en raison des résultats
des dernières élections législatives
c'est la dissolution de l'Assemblée
nationale il a toujours cette
outil dans la main celui dissout de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas le
moment s'il le fait aujourd'hui ça
tournera un référendum anti Macron ça
sera une catastrophe mais le jour où la
nupes et disloquée en raison des forces
internes qui la composent ou des assauts
répétés de l'extrême droite ou de la
majorité présidentielle alors là il y
aura une carte à jouer pour le président
de la République afin de retrouver
une sorte d'assentiment chez les
Français et surtout essayez d'atteindre
la majorité parlementaire qu'il n'a pas
actuellement rappelons rappelons-le il
n'a qu'une majorité relative oui c'est
très important et c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi le 49-3 a été employé pour
faire passer la fameuse réforme des
retraites oui il y a l'autre option qui
est le référendum mais ce serait un vote
pour ou contre Macron pas pour ou contre
ce serait ce serait difficile politique
parce que là bon déjà le référendum on
répond pas toujours à la bonne question
mais alors là même si on répond à la
question ou qu'on répond contre le
présent de la République dans les deux
cas c'est une catastrophe pour lui et là
alors là on s'en relève pas surtout si
c'est lui qui l'organise enfin je veux
dire non non c'est c'est c'est
inenvisageable enfin je veux dire je
sais pour ça je l'ai même je l'ai même
pas abordé
c'était exclu très bien merci beaucoup
Benoît vaut d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui merci à vous d'avoir été
nombreux à vous suivre vous pouvez
retrouver bien sûr le résumé de tout ce
qui a dit Emmanuel Macron vous pouvez le
retrouver sur le site du Figaro merci
une nouvelle fois d'avoir été avec nous
et moi je vous dis bonne soirée sur
filles en live